christian thank you we are seeing henry
ruggs in court for the first time in
months now the former raider appeared
before a judge a bit earlier today let's
head over to victoria saha victoria live
in studio now with the crucial piece of
evidence the judge wants to keep in this
deadly dui crash case
there are two factors that have been a
crucial part in this case how fast ruggs
was driving and the alcohol in his
system today his attorney david chestnut
tried to convince the judge to toss out
the blood work evidence but the judge
says prosecutors can use it
former raiders player henry ruggs iii
stood by his lawyer david chestnut
tuesday morning as he presented to the
judge why the search warrant in the
early morning hours after the november
second crash should be dismissed that
search warrant was approved by a judge
to get a blood test to see how much
alcohol was in drugs system according to
prosecutors ruggs's blood alcohol level
was two times the legal limit when he
was driving 156 miles per hour seconds
before he caused the fiery crash on
tuesday his attorney tried to convince
the judge to toss out the blood alcohol
evidence because he believes it was
taken without probable cause the officer
knew he didn't have enough
and asked not what to do and the
sergeant said don't worry about probable
cause just say there was driving
behavior in a fatality the judge
disagreed is saying when being
questioned by officers ruggs told them
quote he was on his way home from home
after the passenger in his car his
girlfriend told officers they were at
topgolf earlier and had drinks under the
totality of circumstances there is more
than sufficient evidence for a finding a
probable cause a comment that home to
home
is equally consistent
your honor with
being the victim of an being in an
accident
and
suffering head injuries the fiery crash
took the life of 23-year-old tina tinter
and her dog max ruggs faces felony
charges of dui causing death and
reckless driving
i've been in contact with tintor's
family since this tragedy they were in
court today but they declined to comment
on what unfolded ruggs continues to be
at a high level of electronic monitoring
and he'll be back in court in september
for a preliminary hearing to decide if
there's enough evidence to send this
case to trial brian